jetzt gibt es etwas zu gewinnen und die
chancen stehen extrem gut weil ich bin
ein wenig stolz die dritte auflage des
youtube hoch ist raus und ihr könnt es
gewinnen und in diesem video die
erfolgsfaktoren für youtube erfahren es
ist nämlich ganz leicht eigentlich und
ich kann nur aus eigener erfahrung sagen
wenn ihr diese regeln beachtet ist der
erfolg nahezu unausweichlich also los
geht es mit den top-10 erfolgsfaktoren
für den youtube erfolg wahl klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
ja immer wenn ich einen vortrag über den
erfolg auf youtube halten dann sind es
zehn erfolgsfaktoren die wirklich auf
youtube zählen und ich selbst setze sie
bei den united creatures um wo ich
einige kanäle für funk das junge angebot
von ard und zdf betreue zum beispiel
lido fast ein jahr lang haben wir
zusammen gearbeitet und dann erst gegen
der kanal durch die decke noch im januar
2017 waren es 30.000 videoabrufe pro
monat doch dann schnellten die zahlen
von 60.000 im april auf bis zu 8
millionen hoch und jetzt liegt video bei
rund drei millionen views tendenz
steigend hier also jetzt die top-10
erfolgsfaktoren für youtube die erste
lektion oder wie hier bei einem top 10
video ist aus der 10 das
durchhaltevermögen ja worum geht es da
viele menschen glauben die auf youtube
anfang mit dem ersten video kommt direkt
der riesige erfolg das gibt es in ganz
großen ausnahmefällen aber eigentlich
ist das nicht der fall man muss einfach
durchhalten
das kann wochen monate jahre dauern es
gibt zwei indizien die dafür sprechen
dass man erfolg haben wird und das ist
zum einen die watch time also die zeit
die ein video geguckt wird und das ist
die zahl der views wenn die beides
steigt also wenn das wort stand gut es
so ich sag mal mindestens 60 prozent
besser 70 80 prozent und die views
langsam nach oben gehen dann wird
irgendwann der erfolg kommen und da gibt
es den berühmten umgedrehten hockey
stick der geht nämlich so und dann
irgendwann kommt der erfolg aber man
sieht am anfang ist das total langsam
es muss nur nach oben gehen die zahl der
würfe dann wird der erfolg kommen und
die nächste lektion ist wie reichweite
dann geht es darum zu gucken wie komme
ich an mehr views an mehr abonnenten das
heißt wie kann ich meine reichweite
steigern das geht natürlich selbst
dadurch dass man viel twittert 4
kommentare beantwortet mit anderen
youtube an kommuniziert unter videos
kommentiert und so weiter und so fort
und eben auch cola boss macht das heißt
immer gucken
wer es ungefähr gleich groß oder ein
bisschen größer wer hat lust mit mir
kulabas zu machen und übrigens ein ganz
wichtiges kriterium umso besser die
eigenen videos sind umso eher harmlose
lust mit einem kollaps zu machen die
viel viel mehr abonnenten und views
haben also qualität ist ein
entscheidendes kriterium aber das kommt
noch viel später hier in unserer liste
und auf der acht die personelle die
persönlichkeit auf deutsch aber wir
sprechen ein wenig denglisch seit eine
person eine persönlichkeit ein charakter
zeigt wer ihr seid ich bin davon
überzeugt dass der youtube algorithmus
sehr genau darauf guckt ob man wirklich
leute binden kann
denn nur wenn man leute binden kann
bleiben sie auch dabei und abonnenten
und fans und eine community die gewinnt
man durch eine personelle die eine
persönlichkeit in jemand da ist die darf
nicht im vordergrund stehen aber sie ist
entscheidend und wichtig und ich kann
nur dazu auffordern nicht irgendwer zu
sein sondern mal selbst und seinen
eigenen charakter dazu zu nutzen um eben
eine persönlichkeit auf dem kanal zu
sein auf der 7
die community ja das machen vor allen
dingen professionelle produzenten gerne
falsch die denken hey ich mache ein
gigantisch tolles video dann lade ich
das auf youtube hoch und dann wird es
ein erfolg pustekuchen
das wissen alle die ein bisschen
erfahrung mit youtube haben das reicht
einfach nicht so ein entscheidender
punkt ist youtube ist mit facebook eine
der größten social media webseiten denn
youtube ist nicht nur videos sondern
youtube ist eben auch eine social media
community und die kann man nutzen um
seine eigene community aufzubauen likes
discs kommentare abonnements das alles
sind ganz wichtige punkte die man ja
nicht außer acht lassen darf man muss
gucken dass man abonnenten gewinnt auch
wenn sie nachher für den algorithmus
nicht so wichtig sind aber die bauen die
community auf dann auf kommentare
reagieren zu gucken wer setzt discs wehr
setzt likes wann passiert was mit
welchem video erreiche ich wählen und so
weiter und so fort also ganz wichtig
kümmert euch um eure community auch auf
twitter auch auf facebook guckt was am
besten funktioniert ganz wichtig
reichweiten kann man nicht viel schieben
aber man kann die leute ja zur richtigen
fans machen und zu einer community auf
der sechs die leidenschaft das hat nicht
nur etwas mit einer liebesbeziehung zu
tun sondern auch mit dem was man tut
leidenschaft ist wahnsinnig wichtig das
was man macht deswegen mache ich
wissenschafts videos weil das ist meine
leidenschaft das ist etwas wo ich quasi
mein hobby zum beruf gemacht hat das
interessiert mich wirklich ich lese
täglich ich weiß nicht dutzende artikel
über irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse und darüber dann beiträge
zu machen und auch mal vielleicht das
eine oder andere zu entdecken
informationen zu verbinden was andere
vielleicht nicht so machen und das
täglich das ist meine leidenschaft und
ich kann jedem nur raten macht nichts
wofür keine leidenschaft habt nichts was
ich eigentlich nicht interessiert oder
ja wo ihr einfach was euch kalt lässt
macht etwas was euch ja wirklich im
wahrsten sinne des wortes heiß macht wo
er heiß drauf seid und eben wo er
leidenschaft empfindet nur dann könnt
ihr auch den zuschauer die zuschauerin
auf der anderen seite erreichen wenn ihr
für das was er da vor der kamera macht
brennt das ist extrem wichtig also
leidenschaft seit leidenschaftlich auf
der 5 auch extrem wir jetzt wird es
immer wichtiger und entscheidender und
auf der fünf ist programm
lasst eure zuschauer zuschauerin spüren
dass sie ein programm habt dass ihr
regelmäßig videos macht dass sie
erwarten können dass wenn sie euch treu
bleiben dass er sie auch regelmäßig mit
videos versorgt denn wenn sie das merken
dann kommen sie immer wieder wieder und
das ist ein ganz entscheidender punkt
beim fernsehen haben wir ja dass das
bestimmte sendungen immer zu einer
bestimmten zeit kommen und genau so
funktioniert es auch auf youtube wenn er
an einem ganz bestimmten tag zu einer
ganz bestimmten uhrzeit eurer video
online stellt das merkt die community
das merke eure fans eure zuschauer euro
abonnenten und die kommen auch von sich
aus dann wieder und gucken
selbst haye kommt da das neue aktuelle
video das ist ganz entscheidend für den
algorithmus denn sagt dann sagte ihm hey
ich habe eine community die sich
wirklich für das interessiert was ich
mache und mit programm mit etwas was ja
regelmäßig kommt da hilft dir ganz
deutlich eurem euren zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern zu merken hey hier komme ich
immer wieder hin um die und die zeit an
dem in den tag oder ich vielleicht auch
täglich wenn er das schafft ist es noch
besser für den algorithmus und ich
möchte unbedingt die videos sehen die
dann um diese zeit kommen also programm
ganz entscheidend was viele vergessen
auf der vier die online video
optimierung weil online video ist anders
als fernsehen das vergessen viele
ich muss ein video anders strukturieren
das fängt ja schon damit an dass ich am
ende am besten eine end karte ab wo ich
zum abonnieren auffordere und zum gucken
weiterer videos dass das video am anfang
ganz bestimmt strukturiertes dh den
ersten 15 sekunden erzähle ich warum das
das geilste was es überhaupt auf youtube
gibt danach kommt ein grafisches intro
und dann geht es langsam los und am
besten mit einer ganz tollen dramaturgie
wo man etwas ankündigt am besten auch
schon im intro was dann erst am ende
aufgelöst wird wie bei dem tollen krimi
bei einfach einem tollen buch oder einem
tollen spielfilm die auflösung kommt
erst am schluss das ist ganz wichtig da
natürlich titel samt mail video
beschreibung all diese dinge dass man
sich wirklich auf online video
konzentriert und sich darauf
konzentriert was dort anders ist wenn
man da nur business as usual macht also
geschäft wie üblich wie
fernsehproduktionen das oft machen dann
wird man einfach überhaupt keinen erfolg
haben wir nähern uns langsam dem ende
ganz wichtig und wird manchmal vergessen
professionalität und dazu gehört was er
gerade hatten die online video
optimierung es gibt eben professionelle
videoproduktionen zum beispiel die das
vergessen und das ist unprofessionell
aber jedem anderen muss ich auch sagen
guter ton gutes licht gutes bild scharf
deutlich und so weiter und so fort
das ist professionell vergesst es nie
manchmal sehe ich dann eben introns am
anfang von online-videos und das in
einer ganzen reihe oder immer ähnliches
vom nails oder oder oder
das ist unprofessionell seid nicht so
seit professionell vergesst nicht im
ganzen trott das alles wichtig ist das
kann man
und das ist auch leicht aber tut es
nicht dann werdet ihr viel schneller zum
erfolg kommen
und jetzt ein ganz wichtiger fachbegriff
auf der 2 er heißt krass seit krass
macht etwas was niemand erwartet das
kann ein ganz fantastisches thema sein
das kann ein tolles skript sein das kann
ein aufwändiger dreh sein das kann
irgendetwas sein was niemand erwartet
verblüfft die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer und macht dinge die dann auch
weiter geteilt werden weil das ist das
entscheidende bei kras wer im fernsehen
es ist genau das gleiche
die größten erfolge hatten krasse
formate ich sag nur stefan raab mit der
wok wm und der stock car crash challenge
und schlag den raab und so weiter und so
fort das war alles krass die leute haben
darüber geredet am nächsten tag und wenn
er krasser seit und ich sag mal
zumindest einmal im monat ein leuchtturm
video also ein herausragendes video
macht dann wird über euch geredet dann
werdet ihr verbreitet und auch so werdet
ihr schneller zum erfolg kommen das
heißt krasse videos absolut wichtig ja
und auf der einst total abgedroschen
manche werden sich jetzt der hohen zu
halten
ich sag's trotzdem content ist king und
das ist wirklich entscheiden und nicht
irgendwelche content weil viele länder
so hin und denkt na ja irgendwas ist ja
klar konnte den content content eben
nicht irgendwas viele brand channels
also werbekanäle vor unternehmen machen
das zum beispiel falsch die machen
ständig werbung werbung ist kein content
trailer für filme und games ja aber für
alles andere was werblich ist das will
kein mensch gucken es muss content seien
immer mehr werbetreibende begreifen dass
auch aber viele macher haben es noch
nicht begriffen die machen irgendetwas
und wichtig ist dass es wirkliche
content ist also etwas was den zuschauer
weiter bringt besonders gut unterhält
besonders gut informiert verblüffen
toll umgesetzt ist aufschlussreich ist
und so weiter und so fort also macht
wirklichen content irgendwas zu machen
reicht einfach nicht es muss besonders
gut seien besonders herausragend darauf
solltet ihr konzert konzentrieren das
kann natürlich nicht immer der fall sein
ich mache täglich videos und ich kann
sagen nicht jedes video ist herausragend
ganz klar aber ich bemühe mich mit
leidenschaft mit professionalität und
jetzt kommen noch mal alle top tens nein
ich lasse es aber das ist wirklich
entscheidend bleibt dran macht guten
content und dann wird erfolg kommen und
sich weiterbilden informieren soll ja
auch helfen
ich hab da einen kleinen tipp dann ist
es wirklich das steht so ziemlich alles
drin was man wissen muss ich kann es nur
empfehlen
ganz klar ich bin auch ein wenig
voreingenommen aber wirklich fragt leute
die es vielleicht schon haben es ist
echt ein ziemlich umfangreiches gutes
und ausführliches und nahezu komplettes
nachschlagwerk und man hat es glaube ich
ganz flott durch gelesen also viel spaß
dabei und jetzt kommt die schon mit
preisen beantwortet mir eine frage wie
hat ein video auf youtube anzufangen
also im besten fall wie ist es am anfang
strukturiert damit die watch time
optimal ist schickt eure antworten an
info at united creators dot net mit dem
betreff youtube erfolg falls sie es
nicht erwarten können der link zum buch
ist in der video beschreibung genau so
wie die teilnahmebedingungen ich freue
mich auf zahlreiche mails wenn ihr kein
video von pixum verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die knochen
nur dann wäre da auch immer über neue
videos informiert hier geht es weiter
dafür drauf klicken die zukunft des
fernsehens ist online ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran